hula-hoops might seem like simple toys
you know for kids but perhaps not
surprisingly there are some people most
of them adults who are very very good at
hula hooping they compete for things
like time spent hooping the size of the
hoop your hula hooping they even compete
to see who can who the longest
underwater and then of course there are
people who try to see how many hoops
they can keep spinning the current world
record is an astounding 200 hoops but
could it be even higher today we're
gonna look at why hula hooping 300 hoops
is almost impossible to find out what it
takes I hope with the world-record
holder
exhausting talk hoops science with the
neuroscientist but once you have the
hoop afloat like once you've hit the
right impulse in the hoop is moving the
hoop now stays in equilibrium because of
conservation of angular momentum and had
my hooping abilities digitally matched
your hip ankle system was doing its
thing but we saw much more of an
involvement of your knee hoops are some
of the oldest toys on earth and the
ancient Greeks and Egyptians used them
for exercise but the modern tube the
hula hoop dates back to the 1950s there
were one of the world's very first big
toy fads America's newest gift to the
continent the hula hoop craze is
spreading like wildfire in lands already
rabid by rock n'roll plastic hoops sold
by the millions because they're easy
right you just swing your hips and make
them go naturally some people got very
good at swinging their hips and started
keeping track of how many hoops they
could keep going
today marrow out the amazing a performer
from Australia holds the record the
rules are simple hoops have to be
commercially available they have to be
started by the food birth and they each
have to go around a minimum of three
times above the knee to count for the
record and how many hoops is that 200 in
2005 the Hooper named Karina Oates broke
through to triple digits and I was like
that's amazing and then I started
training to beat 100 the next big jump
was in 2009 when Paul dizzy hips Blair
took the record to 132 hoops just blew
it out and I was like that's it
we're all gonna stop retire go home
that's the end but Mara without more
hoops might be possible if she
approached them a bit different I think
when I had the initial hundred as my
goal like I had a hundred hoops that
were all the same size and all the same
white one hoop it's made of plastic does
not weigh that much but if you're
talking about numbers which we are you
bring enough hoops together you're
talking about a lot of weight
[Applause]
and that's not even taking into account
how much space these things take up
because remember you got to pick them up
and get them going all by yourself so if
your arms aren't big enough you're out
of luck I used to just count or a
hundred and then I'd spin them and then
I was like dammit you know I can't get
my arms around it and then I remember
getting the guidelines and being like oh
well if you can have it you can have
this diameter to this diameter by
stacking lighter hoops with varying
diameters Marilu is able to send the
record to 160 in 2014 a year later she
stacked an additional 40 hoops on and
took the record to its current status
200 hoops but doing it was anything but
easy
Marilyn injured herself while training
the muscle around here and I pull I
ripped like the insertion out of it at
one point most people twist their hips
to keep a hoop in motion but Marilyn was
tearing her body apart hooping big
numbers that way with one
physiotherapist who was like if you want
to fix this you're gonna have to
completely relearn how you push the hoot
she had to build a new technique one
that could power massive piles of hoops
around her torso without injuring
herself so when I hold it I plant my
feet I make my legs really strong so
it's like if someone was trying to push
you over you'd be stuck there yep and
then I think much more about using my
core muscles and pushing every time the
hoop hits me in the tummy I push it away
like a laser beam coming out of my
bellybutton and that is what pushes the
hoop around Merrill gave me a lesson in
first with just one hoop and we upped it
to four so these are for regular waste
tubes you want to try and think in your
mind just about the blue one the bottom
one the top ones can skirt around and
move like that but if you keep pushing
the blue one hard enough the rest should
stay on top of it so just keep is that
because the blue is the heaviest no just
cuz it's on the Box on the bottom
stand up straight don't
look down all ABS all ABS ABS ABS ABS
you ready here we go there we go I
didn't have too much trouble with four
hoops but I was still a very long way
from 200 I worked my way up to 14
standard hoops yeah remember I just need
to get to the revolution and then Mara
we'll brought out her record hoops
they're thin and they come in four
different diameters for optimal stacking
this is my hoops are these the actual
hoops you use some of them on yeah then
Mara wha up the angel
this is definitely more than 30 and
you're not gonna tell me how many it is
just yet no afterwards this was very
hard I was clearly struggling close
however many more she had added was
testing my core strength I felt pretty
good
not quiet third attempt that's all apart
pass to the naked eye that was fine yes
alright to the naked eye that counts how
many hoops is this sixteen you smashed
it there we go yeah that's all it takes
I guess that's not all it takes do you
want even though you exhausted just to
feel what a hundred feels like
absolutely how do you get all the way
[Laughter]
you did twice as many yep that's bonkers
Wow that was catastrophic that was
terrible
not even one but a hundred groups is I
have a warm-up for marijuana she
absolutely crushed it so you just made a
hundred of these things look really easy
but no you haven't been training yeah
but how many of you think you could just
do today like right now I I would like
to think I can do at least 150 just like
casual but yeah I'm not super in
training right at the moment but we
could give that a go and see cool I
might have to get into a costume change
yeah serious hoop outfit I've done my
costume change
it's easier to hoop on the skin but when
you who looks like this they pinch I'm
doing it in this is it all marrow is
stacked up 150 hoops and handled them no
problem
[Music]
that look at the knee Mara clearly has a
lot of practice and skill when it comes
to hooping but I wanted to know what
exactly she's doing and what I'm not so
I took a bunch of Hoops to UC Merced
where I met up with this guy and right
there you go
I'm Ramesh Paula super money I'm a
professor of cognitive and information
sciences I study what's known as a
sensory motor neuroscience I study how
the sensory and motor systems in the
human brain come together to produce
skilled human behaviors it's actually
how the brain and the body work together
to perform tasks he's looked at
skateboarding and playing music and yes
hula hooping so we looked at this very
complicated task of how humans control
the hula hoop which is something we can
do with great ease but it's actually it
requires control of pretty much every
part of your body to study hooping his
lab marks up subjects like me with
motion capture trackers it's my crown of
shiny balls yes so we're here in the
mocap lab now I have a crown of milk at
balls and I have a bunch of them stuck
to my body and various sort of points of
interest anatomical landmarks and four
of them around the hoop itself and what
these are going to do is track how the
hoop is moving in relation to my body
and how different parts of my body are
moving in relation to one another to
understand what the body is doing to
keep a hoop aloft you first have to
understand what it is that the hoop is
doing so first we approached it by
looking at the physics of hula hooping
itself so the hula hoop stays afloat by
what's called the principle of
conservation of angular momentum so
angular momentum is like linear momentum
but it's it's it's a conserved quantity
in physics which means that any object
that it had which has to remain in a
certain state will have to have angular
momentum in all of the directions
conserved for it to stay afloat so what
we did with hula hooping was we wanted
to see how the body is assembled into
this complex device that can essentially
balance the angular momentum off what he
discovered is that for most Hooper's
there's a critical relationship between
the ankles hips
and knees that help keep the hoops
spinning around the waist I'm gonna ask
you to do Robby is to poop a little bit
faster you add an extra challenge like
spinning faster right so now you can see
he's involving much more of his knee
joint keep doing what you're doing or a
mental to mentally count backwards in 7
starting with the number 193 eighty-six
things get interesting
79 72 65 when you were doing this
secondary task we're making you focus on
things that are that's not just the
biomechanics were making you we're
changing your attention to something
else and your cognitive load has gone up
and clearly in both those cases we
notice that your hip ankle system is
doing its thing but we saw a much more
of an involvement of your knee got it so
you basically confirmed many things that
we've you know we've seen in our
laboratory studies then I tried doing a
few hoops the way I had with marijuana
so you can see how they kind of fan out
right and then suddenly the energy that
I'm putting into the one I'm focusing on
isn't necessarily right timed to some
other hoop that's like in a slightly
different position in this rotation yeah
right yeah so I think that's kind of
what separates marijuana the rest of us
I'm using my body basically from the
hips down to manage a few hoops but
marijuana is using her whole body to
control a lot of peeps I asked bounce
Romanian to break down how she does it
so this is a video of of marijuana
hooping so it's very clear so she's got
an asymmetric stance with her legs so
one thing that's doing that she's doing
slightly different from our laboratory
subjects is that her left her right leg
or not you know positioned in the same
spot the other thing she's doing as we
observed before is that she's breaking
her lower limbs down into this very nice
hip ankle strategy but more importantly
she is actually created a very similar
amira strategy with her upper limb as
well so by using her upper body Mara was
able to keep as many as 200 whoo
oops going at one time but what's
keeping her or anyone else for that
matter from doing more than that in
Maryland for arms and so much so the
problem is you know once you pack them
as I can't get my arms are a cover I
mean I feel like I could probably lift
to 30 maybe if I could get them going
but I can't pick them up to give you a
sense of how heavy these are I could
barely pick up 200 of them I couldn't
stand up while holding them and trying
to get them to spin numbers look like
probably like an NBA player or an elite
swimmer somebody tall with a lot of core
strength and long arms who can pick up
and spin a giant stack of hoops yeah
someone like that so could we say
marijuana think we've reached a
functional you know maximum capacity of
some kind I would say 250 300 probably
likely anything over that we'll just
have to see depending on you know what
kind of biomechanics that person brings
to the table I'm definitely not gonna
set that record this is only four but
you might and even if you can't just
remember what marrow is doing is already
almost impossible
[Music]